okay so we know that President Obama
warned Donald Trump against hiring
Michael Flynn let's get to Sally eight
Sally eight the former acting Attorney
General under President Obama and for a
few days under President Donald Trump
testified yesterday before the Senate
Judiciary Committee I watched a bunch of
this this was a long time coming going
in I admit I had sort of tempered
expectations that this was going to
really bring much to the surface but Wow
was I wrong the Sally Yates testimony
blew the Trump Russia scandal and
specifically the Michael Flynn situation
wide open and it's very easy Pat if you
sit in front of the the TV or a computer
screen for five hours listening to what
was said it's easy to come away like it
was all legalese I don't know that
anything really came of it but a lot was
discovered and of course Michael Flynn
resigning in shame after it turned out
that he lied about conversations with
Russian officials we later found out
that he's an even bigger liar didn't
disclose that he was a foreign agent for
Turkey long series of problems Sally
Yates shows up yesterday along with
former Director of National Intelligence
James clapper Sally eighths couldn't say
everything right a lot she couldn't say
due to the public nature of the hearing
but she told us a lot she said number
one Russia had dirt on Flynn for some
time and Russia had proof of the bad
things that Flynn had done and would
have been in a position to blackmail the
National Security Adviser of the United
States it appears as though Russia knew
more about Flynn's past than the Trump
administration knew at least at a
certain point in time so not only did
the Trump administration hypocritically
blame Obama for not properly vetting
Flynn before we found out that the Trump
administration had actually vetted Flynn
and knew about his history with Turkey
we know that Obama personally warned the
Trump administration against hiring
Flynn Yates warned the Trump
administration against hiring Flynn
because she knew he would be subject or
could be subject to Russian blackmail
and now we know that Flynn was an even
bigger liability than we were previously
aware of yet Donald Trump still hired
him Yates said quote to state the
obvious you don't want your national
Security Advisor compromised with the
Russians that might be the
understatement of this entire
investigation
Trump apparently didn't care or ignored
the warnings Yates confirmed that Flynn
lied to Mike Pence about his past with
Russia and that the FBI and Justice
Department were aware of the
communications Yates confirmed that it
was British intelligence that first
informed the FBI of communications
between the Trump team and Russia Trump
fired Flynn only once the lies became
public which tells us a lot about Donald
Trump and then the Twitter apoplexy
begins without evidence right before
Sally Yates his testimony Trump starts
tweeting accusing Sally Yates of leaking
information about Michael Flynn saying
quote ask Sally Yates under oath if she
knows how classified information got
into the newspapers soon after she
explained it to White House Counsel now
Sally Yates denied that she leaked
anything about Flynn she indicated there
are numerous other people that could
have done the leaking Yates also said
she wasn't directly informed of her
firing by Donald Trump after she refused
to defend the Muslim ban saying quote
not only was the department not
consulted
we weren't even told about it I learned
about this from media reports she
learned about her firing not from the
individual who had fired her or someone
representing that individual but from
media reports Yates at a later point in
the hearing totally shut down Ted Cruz
on the Muslim ban but we're going to get
to that a little bit later it's sort of
warrants its own segment Sally Yates
testified that the Russians knew for
quite a bit of time as I mentioned about
Michael Flynn's behavior and this big
bake makes the Obama revelations even
bigger don't you think Pat we now know
that not only did Obama warn Trump about
hiring Michael Flynn but we know from
Sally Yates that Russia could have
blackmailed him for a very long time
right I mean we learned a few new things
but by and large this kind of just
confirmed the media reports that had
been cycling for a couple months now but
that's the important yeah because
one FBI director James Comey testified
to the House Intelligence Committee
right and he said that yes the FBI is
investigating Trump we had known that
for a few months based on media reports
but now we have a direct link they're
absolutely right so for people who write
this off by saying this is only
confirming suspicions well when you have
members of the Justice Department
confirming media reports about something
so big that is big in and of itself also
James clapper was their former Director
of National Intelligence and he was
asked how far back have US intelligence
agencies been tracking Russian efforts
to influence the 2016 election and we
know that the FBI investigation went
back to July June maybe even a few
months prior James clapper said
yesterday that US Intel had been
monitoring Russian activity related to
the 2016 election dating back to 2015
that sort of slipped past a lot of
people Pat but that in and of itself is
absolutely major Republicans spending
their time during this hearing just
trying to catch Sally Yates off-guard
and vilify her but she did really well
she was not stumped at any point right
and James clapper is saying 2015 maybe
everyone just thought he misspoke and
meant 2016 right absolutely major
absolutely major and we are going to be
following the repercussions we're going
to talk about Ted Cruz later in the show
and I know Pat is flummoxed by the
gravity of this story as am i to be
perfectly honest send me your thoughts
on twitter at D Pakman also on twitter
at david pakman show follow us there
today's program is supported by one of
our newest sponsors taga dab the hosting
specialists they are offering dedicated
hosting virtual private servers cloud
servers colocation services and most
importantly in my view when it comes to
a hosting company great customer service
and good advice about what makes sense
as a solution for your website or your
project that you're working on they are
very very proud of their team of expert
hosting specialists who also make up
their support team and they give
customers full access to their knowledge
and service they're also rated at a nine
point seven out of ten according to
Trustpilot which puts them at an
excellent ranking you can get a ten
British pound credit when you sign up
for a cloud server at signup tag a DAB
comm slashed edps they're based in the
UK you can be based anywhere in the
world and take advantage of their
services go to sign up CAG adapt comm
/td PS